I'm surprised at the left's message to
men which is that manhood is inherently
toxic you know I love this phrase toxic
masculinity but if you listen closely
and I quote this stuff in the book if
you listen closely to what the leftists
believe they think all manhood is toxic
you know there's one social scientist
who said talking about healthy
masculinity is like talking about
healthy cancer
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is a
U.S senator from Missouri and author of
the brand new book manhood the masculine
virtues a man needs Senator Josh Hawley
welcome back to the Reuben report thank
you for having me Senator I wish we were
recording about 30 seconds ago because
you very sarcastically said to me you're
in DC doing important work and I wasn't
sure if it was sarcasm or not oh yeah it
was it was total sarcasm I think my next
comment was uh ruining the country one
day at a time you know which uh anytime
they say that the Senate's not going to
be in session I usually say it's
probably good right I mean not doing any
damage but in all seriousness the last
two years I mean it has been something
to watch this Administration and their
allies in Congress do what they've been
doing it's unbelievable yeah so my
audience as you know will will fully get
that whether it's borders which I want
to talk about in a second or economy
foreign policy I mean just the whole
freaking thing but so when you're there
now in DC in session obviously the
Republic applicants you know have have
the house back so that's something not
the Senate but the house are you feeling
any momentum to to turn any of this
around or is it just sort of why you
made the sarcastic remark in the first
place well no I think there is momentum
I mean certainly having the house back
in Republican hands is great I mean
that's outstanding we're already seeing
a difference on that uh we should have
had the Senate I mean there's just
really no excuse for Republicans not to
have won back the Senate and you know
other than what Senate Republicans
offered voters which was nothing so if
you don't offer anything how can you
expect people to vote for you I mean
that's my takeaway but certainly I think
that we're able now to stop much of the
Biden agenda we're able to go on the
offensive uh you know this border crisis
is a good example I mean Republicans
actually have a border plan which is
pretty easy it's called enforce the law
we've got pretty good laws on the books
right this isn't hard enforce them the
borders should be closed if you want to
come to this country you should do it
legally if you want to to apply for
Asylum fine you've got to do that
through the legal process and then you
should wait in Mexico or another safe
country say third country while your
claims are processed Etc so I think that
we can certainly make some progress but
listen I mean people can see the reality
I mean this President is a radical
leftist or he's given in to the radical
left agenda and they have been running
roughshod for the last two years and
we've got to turn that around let's just
dive into the Border thing for for a
moment because these videos coming from
our Southern border are insane I mean it
looks like a zombie invasion I'm sorry
every zombie movie you ever see people
flying over the walls that's basically
what it looks like and nobody's really
doing anything I mean what can you as a
senator do when you when you talk to say
Cruz down in Texas what can you do to
help them down there because obviously
the federal government is not going to
do anything
well one thing we ought to do is give
States the power to actually enforce
Federal immigration law and you saw
Governor Abbott down in Texas send a
Texas National Guard troops to the
Border I've introduced legislation that
would say listen I mean the federal
government's not going to enforce our
own laws let's give the states the power
to enforce federal laws I'm not talking
about make the laws I'm talking about
enforce the laws that are on the books
again this shouldn't be that hard so
that's something we should do that's
something that we could do but in terms
of what's going to have to happen we're
going to have to get an Administration
that actually believes in the rule of
law I mean the Border solving the Border
crisis I think is not that hard Dave all
you have to do is title 42 ought to be
permanent we've got to leave it in place
permanently by the way there's
bipartisan support for that on Capitol
Hill and then we ought to have safe
third agreements with other countries
which just means that if if immigrants
want to come to this country and they're
claiming Asylum fine they can apply for
Asylum but they've got to do it first in
another country and if they apply for
asylum in the U.S they've got to wait in
another country while their claims are
processed you can't just come in here
and go into the interior of the country
and disappear while claiming Asylum
we've got to put a stop to that are you
shocked that you know as 2024 rolls
around that that Biden whether it is him
or it's the radicals as you said you
know beneath him in the party that this
is the direction they're going like as
as crazy as the Democrat Party has
become I don't see how this could
possibly be thought of as a winning
thing until you flood us with enough
people that will just vote for Democrats
but in the meantime I think it turns off
a lot of people just Optics wise yeah I
think it's crazy I think what it really
shows though is is their religious
Devotion to their ideology I mean they
are devoted to this globalism of open
borders I mean let's kind of remember
who the base is now the Democrat Party
the base of the democratic party flies
around in private jets and goes to
conferences at Davos like that's their
base now that's who they are they love
this open border stuff they want to
collapse the immigration system they
want cheap labor I really if you ask me
what I think is really driving a lot of
this they want cheap labor and that's
why they like illegal immigration in
particular because illegal immigrants
you can pay them nothing that's what
they want these Global corporations who
are the base of the Dem party they want
the cheap labor so bring them over let
the cartels have free reign and have
kids in Missouri die from drug overdoses
because all the drugs flooding across
the border now that's just collateral
damage the way these people think which
is totally unconscionable and morally
wrong and Joe Biden has that on his
shoulders I mean these are his policies
he's responsible yeah it really it's
just it's just incredible watching these
videos but let's just hit a couple other
things you've also been pretty outspoken
on the Ukraine situation it seems to me
the machine is just endlessly marching
us to war that that it's either about
money funding things giving them weapons
like there's just no off ramp here do
you see any way we can reverse some of
this without World War III
well what needs to happen is we need to
say that first of all we need to give no
more money to Ukraine I mean period I I
voted against this I'm against this
continual funding I mean it's it's clear
to me you you basically are just talking
about escalation and it looks to me like
the bite Administration has a policy of
unending escalation just more and more
and more now we know that there are
actually U.S troops of some variety in
Ukraine we were told they weren't
because of all these intelligence leaks
now we know there are so who knows what
else they're lying to us about but it's
constant escalation more money
apparently the ruling class has learned
nothing from Afghanistan and Iraq like
nothing right down to lying to the
public and lying to Congress at every
turn about what we're actually doing so
step number one well maybe they learned
that they could get away with it is that
what they learned that they can do that
and just it keeps going maybe I mean
maybe I I guess you could argue they
kind of got away with it in Afghanistan
except for you provoke the voters of
this country finally to say no more of
this stuff you know Joe Biden felt that
he had to get out of Afghanistan because
the voters had had enough of this
endless war so you know I think we're I
think we're there with Ukraine as well
but yeah I mean they just keep going and
going so my view is no more money uh
number two we need an accounting of
every dollar that's been spent I mean
this should not be difficult we ought to
know every dime where has it gone what
has it been used for we've sent Ukraine
over a hundred billion dollars even if
you loved what was happening with
Ukraine and you thought the United
States should be fighting on the ground
surely you'd want to know how our money
is being spent but yet I can't get
Senators to vote for basic accounting
but we'll just keep after it until we
can actually get the truth here about
how our dollars are being spent uh let
me hit you on on one other which is just
the economy in general uh you know we
had silicon Bank going down Silicon
Valley Bank about a month ago then about
two weeks ago my bank first Republic is
now part of Chase uh too big to fail
keeps getting bigger what do we do about
this
well first of all I'm totally against
the bailouts I mean let me just tell you
I don't agree with people in Missouri or
anywhere else having to pay for these
billionaires in California to get bailed
out I mean I tell you what would happen
if a bank failed in the state of
Missouri Community Bank failed in the
state of Missouri what they would say is
all these New York Wall Street people
would say is oh
that's the free market we just have to
live with it but when it's full of
liberals who are doing stuff like their
green agenda which is what Silicon
Valley Bank was heavily invested in
apparently oh then it's different then
it's systemic risk whatever that means
then we got then the taxpayer is going
to be on the hook I am totally opposed
to that as to why this is happening the
big banks are out there right now if you
ask me and just talking to people
watching this the big banks are out
there trying to drive down the stock and
trying to drive down the the assets of
these medium-sized smaller Banks because
they want to gobble them all up and the
bite Administration is helping them
they're for that because the bigger the
banks get then the more the government
can partner with the big Banks and they
want three or four banks that will be
basically controlled by the government
because then they can debank and and
de-credit people who don't do what
they're told to do like gun owners and
people who who sell guns for one example
right so we get three or four Banks but
in essence we really just get one bank
because it's the United States
government saying so so what do we do
about that I mean we keep hearing more
about this like Global Currency or
there's going to be this this United
States digital currency you know
DeSantis is fighting hard against it in
Florida it sounds like about 20 other
red states are kind of joining him on
that is there is is it just inevitable
that we'll all continue to go in this
direction no oh no goodness sakes no no
it's not inevitable and we've got we've
got to hit reverse I mean one of the
things I disagree with a lot of my
fellow Republicans in Washington about
is that they've been for this big Bank
stuff I mean they're the ones who have
who have put in place or in some
instances has taken away the barriers
for letting the big Banks get bigger so
what should we do I think we ought to
say to the big Banks you can't get any
bigger sorry you can't buy up any more
of these small and medium-sized banks no
more number two we're not going to bail
we're not going to sweeten this deal by
bailing out all of these Banks because
who profits from that what happens is
the big Banks come in they get the
bailout money essentially and they
gobble up the little Banks so we're
going to stop that whole sweetheart deal
no more of these secret bailouts we're
not going to let the big Banks get any
bigger and we're going to play put in
place laws that actually help and
protect Community Banks like local truly
local banks where you know people know
each other and you can go get a loan
from somebody who knows you and it's not
being controlled and dictated by
Washington or Wall Street makes sense to
me we shall see all right let's let's
talk about the book a little bit because
I was flipping through it this morning
and uh you're you're channeling your
inner Jordan Peterson if I'm not
mistaken
well I think that Jordan Peterson has
been a powerful and much needed voice in
encouraging men all around the world in
his case but men in this country you
need to hear it to say to them listen we
need you you are needed you are
important you can be a force for good
and we need you to step up so turn off
the computer in Mom and Dad's basement
you know come on out go get a job maybe
get married start a family that is how
you're going to leave a legacy that is
how you can change this country and
really the book is about that it's about
how we need men to be all that they can
be so that America can be all that we
can are you surprised that you had to
write a book like this I've heard you
talk about this before the issue about
men in society but look you're you're a
senator mostly people would think oh
he's going to write a book about
politics but that's really not what this
is no yeah it's not about politics and
and I I suppose it is surprising given
just where we are I'm surprised at the
message of the left I'm surprised at the
left's message to men which is that
manhood is inherently toxic you know I
love this phrase toxic masculinity but
if you listen closely and I quote this
stuff in the book if you listen closely
to what the leftists believe they think
all manhood is toxic you know there's
one social scientist who said talking
about healthy masculinity is like
talking about healthy cancer there you
go that that's the less View and they
tell our kids this I've got two little
boys who are school age you know I worry
about what are they Hearing in school
what are they hearing from the media
this is really the big reason I wrote
the book was thinking about my own boys
our boys from the time they're small are
told that being a man is a problem that
men when they are masculine hurt things
break things make Society worse we need
to send the exact opposite message that
we need strong men we need you to stand
up and provide and protect and sacrifice
and you can change your family you can
change your neighborhood you can change
your country if you'll do that we play
the videos on my show every now and
again but if you want to see how toxic
masculinity is go watch the videos from
like 1920s New York City Manhattan when
they have these guys up on those
skyscrapers not strapped into anything
hanging off their you know building the
Empire State Building absolutely
incredible what what was really the
Genesis of it was it really looking at
your kids and going they need a message
on this or I guess where did where do
you think we really went off the rails
on this thing
well I think in terms of why I wrote the
book yeah I've got a 10 year old and an
eight-year-old both boys and then I've
got a baby girl who's my youngest but as
I my boys now get older really for me
the book started me thinking about
what's my obligation as a dad
to help my boys be who they were meant
to be you know I mean what is it that
I'm teaching them and I look at what the
culture is teaching them I'm like man
that is frightening and it is wrong and
so the book really started about me
thinking through that with my own kids
and the book is really about holding out
Role Models I talk a lot about American
history talk a lot about the Bible role
models of what's it look like to be a
strong man and to be a good man and tell
those stories about being a husband
being a father being a warrior building
being a builder being a priest and being
a king and each of those is a chapter in
the book and it's really saying to men
hey there's something that for you to go
after we need you to step up and be be a
contributor in these ways so that's how
it started how do we go wrong I think
it's it's really the left and their
Embrace of this new Marxism which says
that manhood is toxic that manhood is
evil that American society is
systemically racist and oppressive and
bigoted and men are the problem and
that's a message men are told especially
boys are told from the time they are
little and and we've got to counteract
that because it is just dead wrong how
much of that stuff is leaking into your
life your constituents life in Missouri
I feel like people here think about this
stuff they're like all right it's
happening in schools in Cali it's
happening in New York but it's probably
not happening in Missouri
oh no it's in the curriculum everywhere
I mean that's the sad part about it is
that it is it is in school curriculum
and I'll look at the data don't take my
word for it just look at the data look
how often boys young boys Elementary age
boys are diagnosed with ADHD versus
girls versus other demographics right I
mean it is overwhelmingly boys have been
medicated basically into submission in
our schools we've had a constant Mantra
that you know boys shouldn't be allowed
to play aggressively if they bring Toy
Soldiers to schools there's something
wrong with them if they bring a toy gun
to school that's an intervention
it's crazy it starts early and it's
everywhere I mean it's I have parents to
talk to me from all over my state all
over the country come and say that you
know I just heard this happen I just
heard my kid you know brought on GI Joe
to school he was disciplined for it Etc
et cetera it is crazy crazy stuff what
is the effect of that society-wide again
just look at the numbers record numbers
of young men suffering from depression
record numbers of young men trying to
commit suicide record numbers of young
men struggling with drug abuse and
alcohol abuse and record numbers of men
not working so if you like that pattern
then I'd say great keep doing what the
left wants you to do but for those of us
who say no actually we need men to work
we need men to be fathers and husbands
we need men to step up and provide we
got to do something different how much
of this at the end of the day do you put
on the parents I mean I think everyone
gets that the culture is working against
us and okay the movies the TV shows
Disney blah blah blah but at the end of
the day and I say this with the certain
amount of irony I mean I have I have a
basically an eight-month-old and a six
month old so I'm not there yet but like
that it really is you the parent that
should set the agenda here and I think
too many parents probably just didn't
realize that or got lost on their phones
or whatever it might be
well I think that it's it's hard to
parent in this environment when it's
basically you versus the world I mean
when it's you versus what your kids are
being told in school and what we learned
in covet is a lot of times parents they
don't know what's going on in school not
because they don't want to know but
because as we found it in covet
administrators keep it from them yeah
you know I want to see my kids
curriculum oh no you're not allowed no I
want to come and sit on a class oh no no
you're not allowed you know all I want
to see what they're reading no you're
gonna you're a domestic terrorist we're
going to kick you out of the school
board meeting that's what we discovered
in the last couple of years so parents
whether it's schools whether it's big
Tech you know I mean the kids get on the
phone and it's like the Parents try to
monitor it but meanwhile these kids have
constantly pushed to them this imagery
this rhetoric this ideology about how
you know they're not the gender that
they are is not what they should be that
there's no such thing as gender we could
go on and on so I think listen as a
parent myself
a three I I just I have a lot of
sympathy for parents who are like wow I
feel totally overwhelmed and that's one
of the reasons I wrote this book is I
think every particularly every father
out there is trying to figure out I'm
sure it's true of you trying to figure
out okay how can I raise my kids in a
way where they can be all that they're
meant to be and part of that is we band
together we tell the stories that we
know and that Inspire us that call us up
to be something more on something better
how would you scale that up do you think
that really just starts obviously in the
home and then hopefully at the school
and then school board and kind of up
that way or is there a way to kind of
put that on steroids because obviously
we're working against algorithms here uh
that that's a tough battle
yeah it is great point we are working
against algorithms I do think it starts
in the home but I do think that we've
got to strengthen those networks you
know the churches synagogues I mean
these places that are places of real
Community not the virtual online kind
which is fake largely but the real
communities where parents band together
and they raise their kids together you
know around their common values we need
more of that in this country and at the
national level policy level we need
policies that actually encourage that
like we ought to be encouraging marriage
rather than we still penalize marriage
in our tax code I mean it's unbelievable
we're still sending jobs overseas
stupidest thing ever four million jobs
Blue Collar jobs lost to China since the
year 2000 one of the biggest stupidest
policy mistakes in American history
we're still doing it we need to turn
that around bring back jobs where men
can work provide for their families
contribute to their neighborhoods so
there are things that need to be done at
a policy level but really we've got to
put hour in the hands of parents fathers
and mothers and we've got to strengthen
them you mentioned common values so I'm
just back from 10 days in Israel and
four days in Hungary and one of the
things that I found was these are two
countries that despite all their
political disagreements internally and
everything else they have common values
it's very obvious what it is with Israel
in terms of religion and Hungary as a
small country trying to protect their
borders their Christian Heritage etc etc
what do you think the common values are
for Americans because I think that's
what we seem to be struggling with most
it's like we're 350 million people we
all look different came from all these
different places what is the common part
well I think what's in common is is the
history and the principles that unite us
and that you can go to our Declaration
of Independence you can look at our
belief that that we have inalienable
rights that are endowed by a to us given
to us by our creator Now by government
and you look at what underpins that I
mean really the tradition of the Bible I
know I'm not supposed to say this right
this is the left hates it when I say
this stuff but it's just true the
tradition of the Bible has underwritten
a lot of American culture and a lot of
our shared principles and that's been
true whether you were a religious
believer or not it wasn't that long ago
in this country you'd say yeah you know
the principles of the Bible maybe for
some people it's like I don't I don't
think that they're literally true but I
agree with them in principle Etc that
has been our fundamental shared
tradition in this country it gave us
things like Liberty of conscience
Liberty of speech Liberty of assembly
right these fundamental rights and what
the left has been doing is the left has
been running down our whole history and
saying no American history systemically
racist uh American value use
systemically bigoted they want to
overthrow all of it this is the Marxist
element and then they want to overthrow
all of our cultural heritage and I think
we as conservatives we've got to be
about preserving those things that unite
us our basic fundamental commitment to
our inalienable rights our basic
fundamental commitment to Liberty of
conscience Liberty of assembly Liberty
of worship we've got to go back to those
fundamental things that that hold us
together and that includes our Biblical
tradition what do you do about the
people on the other side that just
obviously don't believe that you know
when basically AOC tells Biden that he
should ignore judicial rulings or it's
fairly obvious that half of the party I
don't think I'm being sarcastic and
probably more than half the party they
simply don't believe that the founding
of America is good it's one thing to
have a difference of political opinion
but the the fundamental tenants seem
seem wildly opposite or oppositional
that that I don't know how you get over
that yeah exactly and just to that point
I mean that's the part of the Democrat
Party the the Marxist part that says
that this country was really founded in
1619 right when we were founded on
oppression we were founded on slavery
those are lies and I think what do we do
about it we have to call them out as
lies I mean you just can't compromise
with that you know I mean we can respect
the people I mean I serve with a lot of
these people in Congress respect them as
people happy to have a a discussion
about it but I'm not going to say that
oh yeah that's you know you have a good
point there no you don't actually the
country was not founded in 1619 sorry
that's a lie we were not founded on
oppression America is a nation of
liberators not a nation of oppressors
that's the truth we have to say the
truth you know this country has a deep
Heritage in the Bible that's the truth
you can like it or hate it but that's
the truth we should speak the truth so I
think we've just we've got to tell the
truth this is a Time For Truth telling
in this country and I think that's the
solution and we just cannot go along
with the lies and you can do that
respectfully and you can do that civilly
we should but you got to tell the truth
uh you've been leading on the tech stuff
sort of outside of this but this is
obviously very connected to the tech
side of it I mean I'll watch my niece
flip through Tick Tock and you know you
just suddenly out of nowhere literally
you know she's suddenly It's My Little
Pony and then it's and then it's some
weird gender thing and then five more
videos and something else what do we do
about that and uh you know I know you've
been one of the guys trying to figure
out okay do we do we break them up when
are we supposed to use government power
here well I I just say again as a dad I
would I want to raise my kids my wife
and I we want to raise our kids I don't
want big Tech raising them for me I
don't want some algorithm raising it for
me period so I'm against Tech being able
to track our kids all over the Internet
collect all their personal information
build dossiers on them I think we should
just prohibit that just straight up like
you cannot Target children under a
certain age you cannot build dossiers on
them and I think we ought to give every
parent in America the right to get their
kids information back from all these
social media platforms you got to be
able as a father to go on and say okay
my 10 year old kid and my kids are not
on social media but you know I know the
day is coming I'm trying to delay it but
as a parent I want the right to go on
and say I want from Facebook everything
you've collected on my kid I want it all
back you delete it give it to me delete
it every parent
ought to have that basic right you
mentioned breaking them up I am a big
competition guy so my view is is that
Facebook Google their monopolies I mean
they really are they've tried to kill
comp petition all the time we ought to
break them up and let there be more
competition we ought to we ought to
allow others to get in there to compete
and to have real privacy protections but
bottom line is we've got to give power
to parents got to give them power to
protect their kids to get their kids
information don't allow big Tech to
raise kids yeah did you focus at all on
the on the female side of this I know
that obviously the book is about young
males there's a whole other set of
issues happening with young females many
of them seem to be transitioning more
than males although it's happening both
directions but I assume you think some
of the issues are somewhat constant oh
absolutely and particularly with tech I
mean listen I think the left the left
has a war on the whole idea of gender
it's a war on men but it's also war on
women and look no further than their
campaign to get biological men into
women's sports I mean this is insane we
couldn't even have imagined this
conversation three or four years ago but
the idea that it is now like an Article
of Faith with them that a biological man
must be able to play in women's sports
and use the locker room with the girls
is insane so yeah I think what you're
seeing from the left again from the
Marxist left really is a campaign
against gender it's against Womanhood
it's against manhood there are a lot of
similarities there in how they're trying
to destroy these things that are
permanent these things that are constant
and we've got to stand up for them so
conservatives got to stand up and say no
you know what you don't get to be a
Woman by just wanting to be a woman
there is such a thing as biological
Womanhood and it's awesome and should be
protected and girls playing sports
should be protected and Men on your side
of the aisle your side of the equation
we need you to be good strong men and we
need you to stand up and be providers
and be responsible so we've got to do
both and I think the left is really
attacking both men and women and you you
can see it you can see it in the in the
huge number of kids now who are totally
confused about their gender and say that
they they want to transition they don't
even know what that means and it's being
promoted by leftist ideology and the
alliance with big Tech yeah you know one
of Jordan Peterson's lines on this is
even if you were to take the the kid who
is the point zero zero zero one percent
that has gender uh dysmorphia it doesn't
mean after all the hormones and
surgeries that they're going to be
happier they most likely won't be
actually and that's in the case of when
it genuinely is real which obviously
there's a social contagion element to
this yeah totally and if you look at
those numbers it's really striking if
you look at the breakdown and gender
dysphoria in those cases clinically
diagnosed from say 10 years ago 15 years
ago versus today it is impossible to
argue I think that this isn't a social
contagion you look at it those years ago
and the huge explosion huge win right
around the time the smartphone and
social media really take off and that
every teenager in America has one boom
right then we see huge numbers and it is
the gender dysphoria issue is
concentrated largely in in young girls
in in teenage and preteen girls and
we've seen just off the charts numbers
there and for the left to say stuff like
oh we we have to we have to be for this
we've got to promote gender transition
gender surgery hormone treatment I mean
I think this is crazy when parents don't
know if the parents haven't consented
looking at what that what is really
driving this the social contagion again
the left is so out of touch with reality
and is so contrary to what parents want
are you guys in Missouri doing anything
like what we've done here in Florida
with the parental rights and education
Bill are they are they allowed to do
this in schools without you knowing as
the parent
you know the the Missouri legislature I
think has done some really good work
both on parental rights when it comes to
schools and then also just on this
gender treatment issue saying that
listen you know parents you can't push
this gender trans ideology on kids
Behind parents back you can't do this
without parental consent you can't do
this without getting the miners full
consent so just in this last legislative
session I think our legislators have
done some really important stuff and
it's going to take you mentioned the
states it's going to take the states
stepping up here and creating walls
around the family and saying we're going
to protect parents and we're going to
protect kids and we're going to empower
parents because if we don't do that at
the state level
these the bureaucrats will just run
roughshod over families over kids and
they will push their ideology until they
get what they want yeah you know it's
funny I can't really get Democrats to
come on this show anymore and I'm not
noted as the hardest interviewer and I
would treat them with respect but they
they simply don't want to do it but when
you talk or I'm guessing you know they
don't talk to you that often probably
either but if you're in the Senate
you're wandering around the building the
office is over there and you happen to
see somebody Chuck Schumer somebody that
I'm not talking one of the real real
radicals like someone that 20 years ago
might have been thought of as somewhat
sane did they buy this didn't they all
just vote against a bill that was going
to protect girls in sports every single
Democrat yeah they did over on the house
side and I'm sure they'd vote against
the Senate yeah I don't know what what
their real beliefs are and I you know I
won't pretend to speak for them but I
just think that the radical left
the Marxist left has so captured the
Democrat Party that they live in fear I
think they just live that's why they
won't say the word woman you know they
say people with birthing capacity they
can't even when I say when I say they I
mean Senators Democrat Senators won't
say woman anymore I mean it's just it is
insane insane and I think it is fear of
the radical left who are so powerful now
in their party yeah where do you think
uh education comes into this in terms of
what what a man should do with his life
you know we sort of have this idea that
everybody had to go to the four-year
school we now know that they were
basically brainwashing everybody but
that there were a lot of other jobs and
things that you can do in your life that
are valuable without following that that
path
oh yeah I believe that 100 listen 70
plus percent of American men do not have
a four-year college degree they
shouldn't have to get one in order to
get a good paying job in this country
and be able to provide for a family
that's my bottom line so I'm not for
this shove kids and shove young men in
particular towards four-year degrees
make them take on tremendous amounts of
debt allow them to be brainwashed by the
the university establishment who are
some of the worst actors in America you
talk about what they've done to this
country while taking our money by the
way I mean just taking gobbling up
taxpayer money and yet indoctrinating
our kids so no I'm not for forcing
people to go down that route I think
that they ought to men ought to be able
to learn a trade they want to do that
get an associate's degree not go to
college and they ought to be able to get
a good paying job and I just come back
to the fact that our policy makers have
sent almost 4 million blue-collar jobs
to China in the last 20 years those jobs
are jobs that used to be able to support
family overwhelmingly held by men we
need good blue-collar work in this
country and if we don't get it we're not
going to have a country so what would
that work look like now so let's say
it's 20 it's uh you know January 7th or
January 12th uh 2025. let's pretend
we've got a Republican president it
worked out you either got Trump or
DeSantis let's say what's the policy
that's going to actually bring jobs back
these types of jobs yeah what I would do
is I put tariffs on China I put a 25
tariff across the board on all Chinese
products right now I do it right now we
have a massive trade deficit with them
that is really in my view the most
important deficit that we have and
nobody wants to talk about it it's so
important because it represents money we
are we are giving to them we are paying
them to take our jobs and build their
military on the backs of our middle
class literally that's what's happened
for the last 20 plus years so I'd slap
across the board tariffs on China get
that trade deficit down to zero make it
clear that we're not going to allow them
to use their slave labor in order to
take away the way the wages of our free
laborers here in this country so that
would absolutely begin the process of
bringing back our critical Supply chains
to this country I think we can do more
required that you know listen for our
critical Supply chains a certain
percentage how have to be made in the
United States of America it's a make
America make in America buy America
program and I'm not at all bashful about
this I think we should apologize for
saying that we want stuff made in this
country and we're going to stop trade
cheaters and we're going to stop our
adversaries from taking our jobs I don't
know why Republicans are bashful about
this I don't think we should be well
let's just pray the current
Administration can't bang it up too much
worse and for the next year and a half
all right I got two more now I'll give
you the hard the hard two okay so now
your sons they say to your dad we want
we want to watch whatever's on Disney we
want to watch uh Mandalorian or blah
blah blah you don't want to fund Disney
plus I'm guessing what's the answer as a
father on that one well our answer so
far I mean my boys are 10 and 8 and I
recognize families do this different
ways but but our answer is that our kids
watch very very little TV and they don't
do any social media zero they absolutely
do not have phones they don't even have
iPads and we try to keep our kids off of
social media completely and frankly off
of devices as much as we possibly can
and my wife deserves the credit here she
very carefully curates what the kids
watch she will watch the show before
they watch it and uh you know she's
amazing but that that is that's what we
do and you know it that's that's
obviously hard and this is why I say
it's hard to be a parent right now I
mean I'm a very imperfect parent don't
get me wrong like I'm very imperfect but
it is hard hard when you've got the
whole culture and these huge
corporations against you but uh yeah I
just think we're in an age when it used
to it used to be right when when I was a
kid you think oh Disney wholesome
anything Disney go for it that's not the
case anymore yeah I think there's going
to be a lot of parents busting out their
VHS tapes from Disney movies of 1985
just so that because they don't want to
pay for Disney plus anymore let me ask
you one other purely on the political
front uh obviously this 2025 thing is
heating up it's looking like a trump or
DeSantis situation can you just lay out
I know you're not going to just drop a
name for me but can you kind of lay out
what what you see the landscape looking
like that may lend itself to either one
of those guys well I'll be honest with
you I think Donald Trump's going to be
the nominee I mean I really do I think
he will be the nominee in 2024 and I
think it'll be a a trump Biden rematch I
mean I guess it'll be Biden I mean to me
that's the real shocker I just it's
amazing to me the idea that the
Democrats would re-nominate a man who
clearly he's number one been a terrible
president the worst president of my
lifetime and clearly he's not up to the
job I mean everybody knows this but
looks to me like it's going to be a
trump Biden rematch and I mean I'm sure
it's like know where I'm going to be on
that but I really do think Donald Trump
will be the nominee
Senator I thank you for your time and uh
the link for the book is right down
below appreciate it thanks so much
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell